calling on the world's faithful to join
the fight to solve the climate crisis
40 religious leaders gathered at the
vatican on monday to add their voice to
the growing chorus calling for world
leaders to take real action to tackle
the crisis
the catholic pope pope francis called
the meeting but preferred to let others
speak
i call on all young people regardless of
their religion to be ready to fight
against any action that may damage the
environment or increase the climate
crisis
the meeting was labeled faith and
science and many spoke of the need to
fuse our rational and spiritual sides
together
faith and science people of different
faith
can transform
fear
in hope
anxiety in confidence
in action
into action
others highlighted the responsibility
religion confers on humanity
that the water is the father
the air is the teacher
and
earth is our common mother
just as we don't dishonor
our mother father and teacher
why would we dishonor
these gifts from our creator
we must address the unequal economic
systems and the human impacts of climate
change
though they aren't political leaders the
president of the upcoming u.n
environmental conference says they have
an important role
there is a very unique voice that
religious leaders have when they talk to
other world leaders the leaders of
governments and that i think is what now
needs to happen for that voice from the
religious world from the scientific
world to be amplified to tell world
leaders they have to act to protect our
planet and our people throughout his
papers papacy pope francis has supported
environmental action in 2015 he
published his second encyclical laudato
si in which he called for swift and bold
action to tackle the climate crisis
last week he virtually attended the
youth for climate conference in milan
backing the work of 400 young delegates
as they drafted proposals for the u.n
summit
meanwhile outside conferences a growing
protest movement is adding its own
pressure
a consensus has been building that real
action must come out of the scotland
summit and to that we now have the
support of the world's leading spiritual
figures adam rainey al-jazeera vatican
city